ACROSS TO THE U.S. AND INTO OUR
COUNTRY.
BILL IS LIVE AT THE SOUTHERN
BORDER FOR US IN LA JOYA, TEXAS
WITH MORE.
I'M ALWAYS CURIOUS.
HOW COULD A DRUG CARTEL ASSURE
PARENTS THEY CAN GET THEIR KID
INTO OUR COUNTRY?
HAVE WE MADE IT THAT EASY FOR
THEM?
>> GOOD MORNING TO YOU.
PARTS OF THE BORDER IT IS THAT
EASY.
NOT A BORDER WALL AND AGENTS
CAN'T BE EVERYWHERE AT ONCE.
COMPLETELY OVERWHELMED
PROCESSING FAMILY UNITS.
PARTS OF THE BORDER THERE ISN'T
ANYBODY PATROLLING.
THAT'S THE CASE IN LA JOYA,
TEXAS SOMETIMES.
ONCE AGAIN AS USUALLY KNOW I
SOUND LIKE A BROKEN RECORD.
IT HAPPENS EVERY DAY.
YOU SEE FAMILY UNITS WHO
CROSSED ILLEGALLY INTO TEXAS,
WALK DOWN A ROAD AND GIVE
THEMSELVES UP TO BORDER PATROL.
THESE ONES BORDER PATROL
DOESN'T HAVE TO GO TO THE BRUSH
TO FIND.
THEY'RE VOLUNTARILY GIVING
THEMSELVES UP.
THEY BELIEVE THEY WILL BE
RELEASED INTO THE U.S. AND GOOD
REASON TO BELIEVE THAT.
MAYORKAS SAID HIS ESTIMATION
375,000 HAVE BEEN RELEASED THIS
YEAR.
MOSTLY FAMILY UNITS,
UNACCOMPANIED TEENAGERS, YOUNG
KIDS IS RIGHT.
THE CARTELS LIKE TO ADVERTISE
ON SOCIAL MEDIA THEY CAN GET
KIDS ACROSS THE BORDER INTO THE
USA.
BACK LIVE FOR A MOMENT WE MET
FOR A WOMAN IN CHRISTIE
HUTCHINSON, THE FOUNDER OF
WOMEN FIGHTING FOR AMERICA.
A GROUP THROUGHOUT THE BORDER
CRISIS HAS GONE TO DIFFERENT
BORDER TOWNS AND WORK WITH LAW
ENFORCEMENT AND HAS A
SOPHISTICATED DRONE TO HELP
TRACK DOWN RUNNERS.
WE WERE HERE WITH THEM THE
OTHER NIGHT USING THE DRONE
WITH THERMAL IMAGING.
DIDN'T TAKE LONG.
WE FOUND A GROUP OF FIVE TO SIX
RUNNERS TAKING OFF IN THE BRUSH
AFTER CROSSING ILLEGALLY INTO
TEXAS.
AS THE DRONE WAS WATCHING THE
MIGRANTS USING THE THERMAL
IMAGING THEY WERE RELAYING THE
COORDINATES TO AGENTS ON THE
GROUND.
THEY QUICKLY CLOSED IN ON THE
ILLEGAL IMMIGRANTS.
BECAUSE OF THE HELP OF THE
DRONE THEY APPREHENDED EVERY
ONE OF THOSE RUNNERS.
WE TALKED TO HUTCHINSON WHY SHE
FEELS THE NEED TO DO IT.
SHE IS A MOM AND SHE HAS TWO
BOYS AND LISTEN.
>> DRUG TRAFFICKING HAS GONE UP
OVER 450 SOMETHING PERCENT.
THAT'S A LOT OF DRUGS FLOODING
INTO OUR STREETS.
AS A MOTHER OF TWO YOUNG ADULT
BOYS, THAT HITS ME REALLY HARD
AT HOME.
THIS IS COMING TO YOUR STREETS.
THIS IS IN YOUR NEIGHBORHOOD.
THE DRUGS DON'T JUST STAY HERE
AT THE BORDER.
WITHIN 42 TO 72 HOURS THEY'RE
IN CITIES ACROSS THE UNITED
STATES.
>> AND TO HOME RUN POINT WE
JUST LEARNED FROM THE CDC TODAY
FOR THE FIRST TIME IN AMERICAN
HISTORY THEY ESTIMATE 100,000
AMERICANS DIED IN ONE YEAR OF
DRUG OVERDOSES.
THAT ATTRIBUTED TO THE RISE IN
FENTANYL DEATHS AS WE KNOW
FENTANYL CONTINUES TO FLOW
ACROSS THE BORDER.
>> Harris: YOU HAVE TO START TO
CONNECT THE DOTS.
OR AS OUR VICE